here's a chart that keeps fooling Wall
Street it shows a decade of declining
interest rates the yield on the US
10-year treasury is now around two
percent that's down from around five
percent before the financial crisis but
here's what's interesting check out the
dotted lines they chart wall street's
yearly predictions versus the actual
ten-year ray for example in 2012 as the
economy gathered steam forecasts were
for the 10-year to head up towards 2.5%
instead rates dropped below two percent
analysts and economists have been saying
interest rates just can't get any lower
for years and each time they've been
wrong there are multiple reasons why
Wall Street keeps wrongly predicting
rates will climb they think inflation is
inevitable or that the towering national
debt will cause investors to block at
lower rates in the meantime once again
Wall Street is predicting interest rates
will rise in 2015 in January analysts
were forecasting that rates would be
over three percent by the end of the
year today are just over two percent
we'll have to wait and see if the market
continues to make everyone look like
fools